Microsoft picks is a smarter camera app
that helps you take better pictures
without extra effort it's a bit like
having a professional photographer
inside your camera adjust some settings
choosing your best photos and
automatically enhancing each shot people
are our most important subjects so when
Microsoft pixies a person in earshot it
automatically optimizes focus color and
exposure it also Auto enhances each shot
and lets you compare the difference so
you can be sure everyone looks their
best so you won't miss a moment it takes
a burst of shots before and after you
tap the shutter then it keeps the best
photos and deletes the rest so you don't
waste memory plus when it detects
interesting motion in your photo it also
creates a live image by stitching
together all the first frames into a
short looping video with Microsoft picks
you can enjoy the moment instead of
struggling to capture it point shoot
perfect